so quantum mechanics is random but that
doesn't mean that it's completely
unpredictable there's a rule in quantum
mechanics called the born rule which
lets you figure out the probability that
something will happen if you do a
measurement but the thing is that rule
kind of feels tacked on like there's the
main equation of quantum mechanics which
is called the schrodinger equation and
that governs all the rest of quantum
mechanics and then you have the born
rule which is only for the specific
circumstance when you're measuring
something and it actually is tacked on
when schrodinger came up with the
schrodinger equation there originally
was no born rule in there but it was
added on later because people realized
that that was the only way to get the
correct predictions out but is it is it
actually necessary to add it on
in this video i'm going to talk about a
few proofs that people have come up with
in the last couple of decades that show
that actually you can derive the board
rule from the rest of quantum mechanics
it doesn't have to be added as an
assumption but the thing is these proofs
are honestly a little unsatisfying
because they don't tell us why you had
to have probability in quantum mechanics
or why quantum mechanics is random or
even why exactly does the functional
form that the vulnerable take make the
most sense it just tells us that there's
no other way but the born rule that that
is the only consistent way to assign
probabilities in quantum mechanics still
i do think that these proofs are really
valuable because it means that there's
one less assumption that you have to
take for granted about quantum mechanics
plus as a bonus they're fairly
straightforward to understand you don't
need to know all that much about quantum
mechanics so i'm going to present the
version of the proof that kind of mixes
a few of them together that made the
most sense for me personally so we're
going to start with the uncontroversial
case and that's where you have several
options and all of them have equal
probabilities that is definitely the
least interesting case but the reason
we're going to spend some time on it is
because this is going to be the key to
the rest of the proof when you have a
state that doesn't have equal
probabilities what you have to do is
reduce it to a form where it does and
then because we know what happens in
that case we'll be able to find the
probabilities and then go back to the
original case and so this case is super
important to understand
suppose i have a
electron that can be in three different
energy states
so it could be an energy state a which
is the lowest or b
or c now in quantum mechanics when you
have a situation like this you're going
to actually have the electron b in all
three of them at the same time so the
way that we represent this is by having
the state have
an a component and
a b component and a c component so
usually if there's three different
states that this electron could be in it
doesn't have to be in all three of them
equally it could be for example much
more in a and the way that we would
represent that is by having a number in
front of a that's sort of bigger than
the number in front of b and c but in
this case we're going to consider the
example where these three numbers are
going to be exactly the same and so in
other words these three states are sort
of equally represented inside of the
state of the electron i've made this
number into a square root of a third and
i'll explain why for people who are
curious but if you want to skip ahead
feel free
so this is called normalization and it's
where when you take the modulus squared
of each of those coefficients and you
add them that this will equal to 1.
now this might seem like it is due to
the born rule because it's about
probabilities but it actually has
nothing to do with probability it's
because in schrodinger evolution so the
rest of quantum mechanics without the
born rule you can assume that the length
of every vector is one because the
evolution under the schrodinger equation
will preserve that length and so you can
just like pick what length you want it
to be and for convenience we pick it to
be one
okay so what does the bourne rule tell
us in this case
well you have these options a b and c
and if you were to measure the energy
you would get one of those
with some probability but what is the
probability that you will see the
outcome a
the bond rule says that you take the
coefficient in front of a
so that is the square root of 1 3 and
you take the modulus square of it the
modulus square is just the same as the
square in the case where all of these
are real which is what we're going to be
dealing with so you may as well just
think of this as squaring which is the
same as one-third
and so that's the probability but we
didn't really need the bone rule to tell
us that in this case i mean if we just
looked at this original state we can see
that a b and c
have exactly the same coefficients in
front of them and so whatever their
probability is all three of them ought
to have exactly the same probability we
don't need to have gone via the born
rule
so this is one case where the bond rule
is clearly completely unnecessary but
can we now use the same kind of thinking
to prove that the born rule is
unnecessary for more complicated cases
okay so this video is sponsored by
brilliant which i'm really pleased about
because up until recently i was working
for brilliant and i really love what
they do brilliant has some great courses
on quantum mechanics including a new
course by sabine of youtube fame and a
course on quantum computing i should
point out i wasn't involved in writing
those courses though i did contribute to
some other courses that i might talk
about another time but anyway these
courses use interactives so that you can
learn quantum mechanics in a really
hands-on way but brilliant also has
courses on a whole lot of other topics
in math science and computer science
another one i really highly recommend is
a course on linear algebra because it's
written by people who really know their
stuff and it is a great way to learn
exactly the mathematics that you need
for quantum mechanics so to get started
for free visit brilliant.org
looking glass universe and the first 200
people get 20 off their annual
subscription
yeah brilliant's great go check them out
okay so here's a more complicated state
you have something that's a
superposition of a
and z and you can see that it's more of
z than a because this number in front of
a is smaller than the number in front of
z in fact according to the born rule you
would say that the probability of a
is equal to taking that coefficient and
squaring it which is equal to a third
and the probability of z is equal to
taking the coefficient and
getting the modular square of that
which is two-thirds so this is the
outcomes according to the born rule but
is there some way for us to completely
forget about the born rule itself and
still come up with the same
probabilities the trick is to break zed
down into two different states let's
call them
b
and c
so this is what i mean the original
measurement was of a and z but you can
think of zed as just being a sort of
course measurement where you can't tell
whether the actual outcome is b or c
so for example imagine we're back to the
original scenario where we had these
three states a b and c and they
represented energy levels z would be the
state where
the energy is
greater than a but we don't know whether
it's b or c
so now the original state is one that
says that there is some superposition of
a
and
z which is itself a superposition of b
and c
so another way to think of that is that
the a z measurement is when you can't
get full resolution on your measurement
you want to find out what the energy of
the particle is but you're not able to
figure out whether it's a b or c you can
only figure out if it's a or bigger than
a so the way to represent that in
quantum mechanics is to write z as a
superposition state between b and c if
you're wondering why i've made the
coefficient square root of 1 over 2
that's just a normalization thing
because i want this to have length 1
because z is a vector of length 1 and so
that's the only way to do it but now
that we've rewritten z this way let's
rewrite the entire original state in
terms of this new z
now that i've subbed that in
let's go ahead and cancel
this with those coefficients
so the twos disappear
and once we've expanded and simplified
that all we see that the original state
now looks just like that state we had
before where it was an equal
superposition of a b and c
which makes sense because that's how we
kind of designed it we wanted to say
that this superposition
is the same as having this
and this
which we can now break down into three
parts
which is that
and that the really clever thing that we
did was we made sure that these
coefficients are going to be the same
for all three of them and so if you were
to go ahead and directly measure whether
the energy is a b or c each of them is
equally likely that's really useful
information for us for the original
measurement as well the az measurement
because imagine that i measured whether
the energy is a or whether it's z and
then if i got the result z i would go
and do a further measurement which was
to figure out whether the energy is c or
b
then i would expect that the
probabilities that i get for
a b and c or to be still a third
a third and a third because you can
think of them as this state where each
of them has an equal probability but
that tells us the probability that we
got z in the first place because the
probability of z is equal to the
probability of c plus b
and it ought to be two thirds so what
we've just done is that we figured out
the probability of z without having to
assume the bourne rule at all instead
what we did was we rewrote the original
state which was not an equal probability
state and we made it into an equal
probability state from that we knew the
probabilities and then we ported them
back over to the original
this was just one example of when we
didn't need the bone rule but there are
actually many more examples that are
very very similar let's consider the
case where these are the two
coefficients we're going to play the
same trick of breaking both a and z into
finer states
and then rewriting that whole thing as
an equal probability state so how many
different states do you think we need to
break a down into and how many for z
we actually need to break a into two
states so i'm gonna call them a one and
a2
and we need to break z into three states
the coefficients in front of a1 and a2
is
one on square root two
and the coefficient in front of these uh
1 on square root 3.
you might be wondering am i always
allowed to take a state and break it
down into a state like this
the answer is yes because what it
amounts to is saying that the original
measurement you were going to do which
was whether it was a or z
is actually a coarse grain measurement
and you could get a final result by
measuring whether within a
the result is a1 or a2
and within z whether it's
z 1
2
or 3. okay so let's substitute this
state into here
and this state into here and see what
happens
as before you get some cancellation
and once you shake all of those out you
get this which is a state where there
are five different options and all of
them have the same coefficients and so
in other words they all have the same
probability so the probability of all
five of these is a fifth which means
that the probability of a is a one plus
a two so it's two fifths
and z is
three-fifths
and there you go another case where you
found out the probability of a and z
without having to resort to the born
rule at all
this sort of trick is going to work any
time that these coefficients are the
square root of rational numbers what
about the much larger case where this is
actually irrational there's lots of
different ways to get the irrational
case to work and all they amount to is
taking the case that we've already done
and extending that result to the
irrational case by assuming some things
about the probability function so you
might want to assume that the
probability function is continuous or
maybe you want to assume that the
probability function is independent of
the dimension of the hilbert space that
you're working in so whatever way you do
it you basically want to say that
because we know it for this case the
function is constrained so it acts the
same way which is that you take the
coefficient in front of a
and
you take the modulus square of that
coefficient so that's it that's the
proof of the bone rule i know it wasn't
particularly satisfying and whenever i
find proofs like this where i can
understand what happens at each line but
overall i don't feel like i really got
what went on i'd like to at least like
step back and see mathematically uh what
made this proof work and here it was
really simple basically what made it
work was the fact that we know that this
function this function that we're
looking for
acts a certain way when these
coefficients are equal
we know that what it does is
it takes the modulus squared and the
reason why we know that is because yeah
we know that that probability has to be
a half from this fact in this very very
simple case and using the fact that we
can take any other state and basically
break it down to look close to um an
equal probability state we get the full
bond rule so there you go you didn't
have to assume the born rule after all